[Music]
breaking news at 6 30 North Las Vegas
Police releasing body cam video of a
deadly officer involved shooting nine
days ago all right so we want to warn
you this video
me disturbing to some View
hi Felicia sit down in that chair right
there
so we have chosen to freeze the video
after this officers opening fire and
shooting 43-year-old Felicia Goosebumps
police say they're responding to 9-1-1
calls about a domestic incident in that
home there in North Las Vegas when they
arrived they found a 75 year old sitting
on a bench and learned that a female was
inside the home that's when the video
shows Guzman walking out and waving a
knife around moving towards the officers
according to police she did not comply
with their orders to put the knife down
that's when they opened fire Guzman died
from her injuries both officers are on
routine paid administrative leave
happened May 16th near MLK and Gowen in
North Las Vegas